you know this battle royale was bound to
happen two of the best foldable phones
of 2023 thus far are in my hand first
the Samsung Galaxy fold 5 reviewed this
a few weeks back one of the better
foldable phones on the market to date
however recently we got in our hands the
allnew xiaomi mix F 3 like a camera
setup also Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 four
cameras on the back but we're going to
take these through their Paces let's see
who is going to be the foldable champion
on of
2023 here at geek culture we've tested
plenty of chairs but Secret Life gaming
chairs remain one of our favorites
whether it's for work or play they feel
great to lean back against with the
ergonomic features offering support for
the whole body from the head and back to
the arms and even something for your
butt this mix of Form and Function helps
the Titan Evo 2022 deliver the best
seating experience like no other for
more information check out secretlab.co
talking about the F 5 here as we
mentioned earlier it's got a very narrow
sort of oblong shape to it much better
built in the previous fold phones which
are already very good in terms of the
design and build quality this has the
zero Gap hinge on it now so there is no
sort of gap between the displays which
is nice all the other foldable phones on
the market pretty much have that covered
Samsung is a little bit late to the
party as I mentioned in the previous
video but they're finally here um
outside of that though it is a quite of
a slippery phone and there's no case
that comes inside the box so um I would
defitely recommend getting some sort of
silicone or some sort of cover for it
because if your hands are you know get
sweaty or you're in a hotter climate
like we're here in Singapore this can be
very slippery to the touch zachie don't
hit that car behind you this guy wants
to leave here very soon I'm looking out
for zachie as he's walking and talking
because zachie is the machine with one
arm doing the gimbal thing as a matter
of fact zachie we've got to do the shot
so people believe me when I talk to you
about this this is with the full five
those bright vibrant Samsung colors
coming into action look at that that's a
shot right there there that's going to
get you so many swipes oh man that's on
point here is the mix full 3 photo mode
look at those Leica colors popping into
play there oh zachie looking good baby
looking good little bit bright a little
bit Overexposed but that's what happens
with these camera phones most times are
not all right so continuing with the
fold five here for a second here as I
mentioned Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 processor
in this Flagship specs the cameras are
not necessarily Flagship and neither are
the mix full 3 but they're pretty much
part and parcel that's what makes this
very good uh system to compare it with
now in terms of the UI and the ecosystem
I mean xi's got a very vast ecosystem
but of course the mix full 3 not
available outside of China you know it's
not designed to be available outside of
China so there probably will be some
limitations whereas the fold 5 is so
that ecosystem I definitely would say
would give it to Samsung versus the
xiaomi in terms of that but in overall
design I'm not in love with this phone
because it's a little bit too narrow for
me and it's a little bit too slippery
very well built but I like to have some
sort of matte texture around the bezels
just makes it a lot easier instead
instead of this slippery sort of uh
stainless steel or aluminum or whatever
it is but now let's talk about the mix
fold 3 and the design on it which I
personally prefer now we're going to
talk about the mix fold 3 next to my uh
my associate here in the Kong you know
you know frying up some nice Sate there
very very good as we call like to say
Sad anyway let's talk about the mix full
3 this has a much more traditional phone
design in terms of its the width and the
height it so the only real difference
you're going to notice of course is that
it's a foldable design but it is zero
Gap as well there is no gap between the
displays which is a welcome addition
however you might not some notice
something on this phone that's different
from the fold five I have a case
actually covers and they come inside the
Box how about that you buy a foldable
phone and actually they put covers
Inside the
Box the blasphemy of this company look
at these they come inside the Box how
dare they even put a charger in a cable
wow
$1,800 for
this and I only get a
cable xiaomi S I get a nice textured
cover for the front and back to protect
my worthy investment outside of that
though this is a very well-built phone
feels fantastic on it and there are a
couple different options with the mix
full 3 you can get the aired fiber back
on it which is not this feels more of a
sort of like faux leather back but again
this is a Le a collaboration so you have
to a little bit of luxury inside this I
prefer this it feels very very good in
the hands and the metal around this is
also more of a matte finish as well so
it's much easier to grip the mix fold 3
is slightly narrower than the fold five
and it feels that way in the hands too
and also what I like about this as well
it's the small things that matter is
that it's not flat on the edges so it's
much easier for your fingers to actually
grab the displays and open it up versus
the fold five where it's flat there is
no sort of GrooVe at all so you really
have to sort of get your fingers inside
there and it can be very slippery and it
can be very U costly if you slip and
drop it whereas this is a much more
tactile experience and it makes it work
great and by the way the display you can
position it however you want and you're
good to go same like the F 5 so in terms
of design I'm going to give the award to
the mix fold 3 hey zachi come close a
little bit I want to show you the best
part of this case here look at
this stand
the stand is built in the case this is
Metal by the way inside no extra
charge sh me thank you I'm standing with
pride now I've got a case that stands
and it's free not really got to pay for
the phone but still it's inside the Box
anyway that's it for the design let's
talk about the cameras next all right
first we're going to be testing the
front-facing camera in terms of video
now unfortunately like all xiaomi phones
there's no 4K the Max is 1080 so I'm
going to do 1080 60 here and we're going
to see how this looks how the audio is
in terms of the recording so I'm
recording with the front facing camera
now at 1086 it's a very smooth image of
course and iow I record this at 60 so
Zachy can play around with the frame
rates a little bit more in case he wants
to match everything but this is a really
nice image uh the sky is blown out
behind me you see no sort of uh blue at
all it's completely white I'm exposed
but the sky is not so H not too sure
about that anyway we're going to try it
now with the fold five so because the
Samsung can actually be recorded in 4k
60 I'm going to be doing that right now
and as we see we see a little bit more
of the blue sky behind me a little bit
more better dynamic range versus the
xiaomi but that's always been Shia
xiaomi's Achilles heel is the
front-facing camera in terms of video
this is really good Samsung does a great
job with video so I expect nothing less
from Samsung the winner in this test
clearly goes to Samsung and I got to
tell you but one thing about this I will
tell you at 4K 60 or even 4K 3030 it's
kind of contrasting it's very very sharp
so you see all the imperfections on my
face um so I might need a get a sort of
a diffuser cover that up soften my look
a little bit I can put some beauty mode
on this but I'm keeping it natural so
you guys can see what it's like out of
camera but nonetheless the winner is
Samsung by 10 fold so now we're
recording with the rear camera's ak30
out of the fold five this gives you an
idea of how it performs and I'm I'm
guessing the autofocusing is going to be
equally as good as it was with the front
facing Samsung's never had an issue in
that regard but we're getting 8 k30 now
not every phone does 8K but Samsung is
delivering it with the fold 5 and this
is what we have in terms of the image
quality also you're going to hear in
terms of the audio quality as well let
me know what you guys think in the
comment section below now let's go to
the mix full 3 we're testing ak-2 24p
out of the xiaomi mix full 3 does not do
ak30 so there will be a little bit of a
frame rate difference on that crying
baby we did not pay for that baby to be
in the shot it just happens we're
shooting on the streets of Singapore and
Anything could happen at any point in
time you're getting a sense of what the
stabilization is like what the colors
are like what the exposure is like and
also what the audio is like what do you
guys think which one is the better
system for 8K let me know in the comment
section below the baby has an opinion
but we're not going to ask the baby
right now because he or she's undecided
so let's talk about the cameras on these
phones now as we talked about with the
fold five these are not Flagship camera
specs that are inside this device it's
not like the s23 ultra and likewise with
the mix full 3 these are not the
flagship that we're seeing out of the 13
Ultra the 13 Pro for that matter but
what you are getting out of the xiaomi
is that collaboration with Leica still
so you're getting that like authentic
like a vibrant color schemes you also
can change the colors through monochrome
and various different uh simulations
inside the camera plus you get that
beautiful bokeh that gives you a much
more of a photographer's look to your
images versus the Samsung which just
looks perfect in every way and the
customization in the mixed full three in
terms of Photography does make it a much
more enjoyable to tool to use versus the
full 5 not to say that this device
doesn't take good photos it does but the
photos just look vanilla whereas with
the mix F 3 with the like of
collaboration they have a bit more
character now these are my own personal
opinions you may differ from me but this
is what I'm seeing out of the camera
systems in terms of video I'll give the
edge to the fold five but in terms of
photography I really like the colors out
of this I like the usability and I like
the functionality now like most
smartphones out there and I've seen some
of your comments you probably you've
asked me in the past why are my phone so
Overexposed
this seems to be a a trait of a lot of
smartphones nowadays to sort of get
everything exposed correctly what I tend
to do is I manually drop the exposure
down to make those colors a little bit
more Rich a little bit more contrast
bring down the Shadows a little bit more
to make it more look organic like a real
photograph out of out of a mirrorless
camera system or DSLR for example versus
a smartphone camera where everything is
exposed bright and shiny and just
perfect I like a little bit of
imperfection in my camera systems and
the xiaomi gives me that look but at the
same time delivering fantastic image
quality so let's talk about battery life
on these two phones Now battery life is
decent I will tell you that I have had
no issues in terms of using these all
day and because the brightness is not so
severe on the mix full 3 I mean you're
not pushing these phones to Max
brightness anyway unless you're going to
be outdoors like we're at right now
we're in the shade because it's actually
quite hot here in Singapore but I find
the battery life definitely more than a
day for most people out there now I'm a
power user so that depends on my usage
if I'm going to be shooting more video
maybe not so much but no complaint on
that in terms of the UI obviously this
is running the Mi UI on this as versus
this is the uh you know Samsung's own UI
and these are going to be a personal
preference now xiaomi's own UI does work
relatively well it's built into their
ecosystem it's very iphon esque in a lot
of ways which if you're coming from an
iPhone or have an iPhone and this is
going to be your secondary device you're
going to appreciate the similarities
whereas Samsung is a little bit
different but I would give the edge to
Samsung in terms of the versatility
using the Spen being able to do
multitasking in many different ways the
mix full three you can do some of that
but not to the extent of the Samsung
this is where Samsung has really sort of
pioneered the full market and the larger
phone display Market because of the
ecosystem and the flexibility that you
can do with these devices but I would
say that this is not so bad but I would
say this is more of a phone SL larger
tablet but still basic phone F uh
functionality versus the fold five which
is sort of a tablet that you can fold up
to via phone my final thoughts on these
two phones are this the mix full 3 is a
fantastic device but as I mentioned
earlier in this video it is a china-made
device only you can buy it of course you
can import it into your respective
country but you are going to be limited
on warranty and also support versus the
Samsung full 5 which is available
worldwide has a lot of great support
from Samsung in terms of warranty on the
inside display which you know buying an
expensive phone like this there's some
Merit to that and something that I would
say heavily consider especially if
you're going to be investing this kind
of money into a device not to say I
don't think you should buy this but buy
it at your own risk but if uh history
has proven us uh something that with the
12s Ultra that was made for China only
back in the day then the 13 Ultra was
made worldwide we may see that happen
again with a mixed fold for for example
if that comes to Market in next year
maybe they'll release maybe they'll
release this worldwide and hopefully
they do because this is a very very good
device paired with xiaomi Eco system if
didn't have the Chinese ROM on it to it
we' have more accessibility to it and it
would really give the full fiber run for
its Mone as it stands right now as a
Content creators tool if I'm looking for
photography only mix F three if I'm
looking for video F five in terms of
ergonomics mix full three in terms of
support full five and those are my
thoughts on these two phones let me know
your thoughts in the comment section
below if you like this video also check
out more of our phone comparisons right
here